o meu coração
[Música]
é isso hoje então acompanhei o treino
físico do Whindersson Nunes para a luta
Vamos fazer um circuito
[Música]
vai
mais uma mais uma deu troca correndo de
baixo para cima assim
não
fica com as peças aqui
[Música]
isso aí beleza
vai 321 aí agora sim vai
[Música]
10 segundos acelera sempre o final vai
vai vamos embora bora bora
prepara três dois um foi
os dois explode
e só vai
vai
andando em volta
[Música]
não tem problema vai fazendo do seu
jeito até pegar a manha
isso aí você vai circulando no ringue
isso
[Música]
à direita vai estar aqui se já vai cair
o quadril bom vai concentração Bora foi
vai foi vai vai vai
volta já arranca vai vai vai aí mais uma
prepara 321 foi vai vai vai vai vai vai
sai arranca vai
deu já entra no pneu
vai embora mano
vai então vamos É Para Isso mesmo esse
circuito é para isso de resistência
vamos 3 2 1 vai foi vai concentra alta
olha para frente respira
isso vamos ponta do pé perna leve Bora
vamos
isso vamos ponta do pé ponta do pé vamos
lá entra e sai entra e sai entra e sai
entra e sai vamos solto no ringue vai
completa completa vamos vamos vamos
vamos vamos
10 segundos fica na frente do pneu
pula pula
para lá devolve o pneu
vamos pula
vai vai pula
deu respiro galera seguinte a gente está
fazendo hoje o treino de preparação
física com foco na resistência dele
então a gente está fazendo rounds onde o
tempo final é o mesmo tempo do round de
luta dele ou seja 3 minutos na
segunda-feira a gente procura fazer um
trabalho mais de força com ele então
supino agachamento algo que ele fique
mais forte e nesse treino de hoje em
específico que a gente tá gravando para
vocês é o treino que a gente busca a
resistência dele deixar ele mais
resistente deixar ele mais
como que eu posso explicar a recuperação
dele seja mais rápida entre os hounds ou
seja ele faz um round intenso já senta
para recuperar que isso seja de uma
maneira mais curta Então esse é o foco
do treino de hoje resistência que é o
terno que ele fica puto onde ele cansa
ele não quer fazer ele mete logo que ele
não sabe fazer os exercícios mas ele
sabe por isso que eu vou ter que
aumentar uma volta pra ele então
acompanha o trem de preparação física
[Música]
isso vamos vamos vamos
bora bora bora bora bora bora bora bora
vamos vamos 10 segundos
foi
os dois Bora
os dois Bora entra sai entra sai
[Música]
10 segundos 10 segundos confunde ele no
final do round Bora entra sai em
movimento vamos vamos isso isso perfeito
é isso aí deu lá fora 3 2 1
vai foi vai vai
respira 10 segundos pneu
isso isso
vamos
devolve última
respira por último
Cruel esse é o treino que realmente é
muito mais puxa o atleta fora de box né
dele Claro mas esse é o que a
intensidade vai no alto parece que você
fica sem ar e tudo mas é o trabalho que
faz ele ficar resistente por isso que o
Whindersson tem uma base muito boa ele
não cansa porque a gente sempre fez esse
trabalho e agora a gente tá fazendo ele
mais intenso focado aí para a próxima
luta de box dele mas eu tendo que ele
fica bravo porque ele fica cansado enjoo
e tudo mas bora que é o que faz ele
ficar melhor
agora a gente vai fazer uma parte de
força no final a gente vai fazer terra
com um supino na máquina baixa as
repetições deixar o homem mais forte
agora um
dois três
quatro
cinco
seis mais duas
sete mais uma
foi
bom
[Música]
dois três
quatro
cinco
seis sete
oito vamos 9 vamos
[Música]
[Aplausos]
Sim vamos
8 + 12
[Música]
9 + 1 10
é isso mas é isso que vai deixar
resistente para Luta
então vamos deixar ele voando